One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night.
I love the privacy of it. And also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know, Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group. You know, we did that one year with my family.
We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure. There's so many things I wanna do and see. Like redoing the basement without having to do it all myself. next adventure. Performance matter. And now you can get $300 when you invest with RBC. Offer ends March 3rd, 2025. Terms and conditions apply.
Invest with RBC today. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories.
We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Hey there. I'm smiling again. I know it's the second part of the edge and you couldn't be more tickled. Yes everyone, welcome back. You know, once we got into it,
we realized we had a lot to say about this movie. Yeah, we needed to make it a two parter. Because it's so good. I think Angela, wouldn't you agree it's just because it's so good, there's so much to say? There is a lot to say. Wait, but it's because it's so good. It's good, lady.
It's good. It's so stressful for me, but I'm here for you. You know, maybe if that reviewer guy, James, listens to our breakdown, he'll gain a new appreciation for the movie. Wow. You are still really sour about James. I might write him a letter. He might get a letter from me.
He's gonna be so confused because he wrote his review in 1997. Yeah, you know what? It's never too late. It's never too late. But first, I said last week that I would tell you what to do in a bear attack. Oh, I have been waiting for this. I'm grabbing my cup of tea. Well, let's get to it. First of all, brown bears, like the one in the movie, are more aggressive than black bears. However, the chances of being attacked by a bear are exceedingly rare. But it does happen. And according to all the experts, staying alive during a bear attack requires a presence of mind that is difficult for humans to muster under pressure.
You think if a 1700 pound thing swats you and you go flying that you're gonna be like I'm gonna think right now. Well, this is why humans don't do well during bear attacks because we can't think ourselves out of the situation. You can't process what's happening. Yeah. The injury patterns for bear attacks include blows to the face, head, chest, neck, and upper extremities most likely. And even if you do survive the attack, your injuries can be anything from like major lacerations to fractures. You know like when the bear is just like pouncing on your chest, it's just like crushing your rib cage, to like internal organ damage. These are all things that are more likely to kill you than the lacerations actually. The
National Park Service said that the most important thing to do if you encounter an approaching bear is to stand your ground. Do not run. Instead, you're supposed to wave your arms, try to look or become as big as possible, even if it means you have to try to get up on a hill or something. But never scream and never, ever make bear sounds. Don't growl at the bear. And then when you move away you're supposed to go sideways. Don't go backwards because that is seen as like retreating. Yeah,
try to go sideways. So you, okay, let me see. I think I've got this. Okay. Wave your arms around. Yep. Don't make a sound. Side step. Yep. If the bear charges you, this is where I think, I don't know how you do this. Do you charge it back? Nope.
You just stand there. Ugh. What about laying down and playing dead? No, no, no. No. They'll just flop you around. In most cases, a bear will veer off at the last minute. It's just like a really intense game of chicken. The vast majority of bears are uninterested
in humans and once they get close enough, like if they're charging you, once they get close enough to smell you and recognize you as human, they should retreat and go away. But a bear will attack anything that it deems to be fleeing prey. The National Park Service says to be especially cautious of mama bears and cubs, never get in the middle of a mama bear and her cubs. If they're walking in a line, don't cross it. Do not get in the middle of them.
Also, do not climb a tree to get away. They will get you. If you're trying to escape a bear and you're wearing a backpack, keep it on because this might serve as protection. If a grizzly or a brown bear does attack you, lie flat on your stomach with your hands behind your neck and spread your legs so that the bear can't flip you over. If you try to fight back in any way, it might increase the intensity of the attack.
So you want to save fighting back as a last resort. If you feel like you're in a last resort situation like Steven was in the movie... Go for the nose? The face. Find an object and hit the bear in the face. Like, try to find a rock and just smash the bear's face Mm-hmm. That's for brown bears. If a black bear attacks you don't play dead
This is look at all you have to be observing in this moment. Well the brown bear you said stand your ground Don't play dead. Until it's attacking you then play dead. And spread your legs and cover your stomach. Starfish. Yep there you go. If a black bear is attacking you it's said to try to get into a closed vehicle or building. I mean duh. I mean where is there a closed building or a vehicle if you're somewhere where they're around. I don't know. But in the rare case that a bear is stalking you and maybe like attacks you while you're in your tent or something, this is a predatorial bear and fighting back is the only option. Very, very rare. But kind of true that like the bear in this movie is hunting the people. bear in this movie is hunting the people. I guess every once in a while. Finally, if you want to hear an amazing story of a bear attack. Oh, is it that podcast? Seth Rogan's Storytime? It is so good. Yes, he interviewed a guy who fought off a bear
attack and lived. It is riveting. Riveting. It's in Canada. And there's all these real people that tell their, like, eyewitness sort of accounts of it, including the main guy. Yeah. So good. I will definitely share that in stories because I thought it was so well done. Yes, Stu. Well, before we go to break, Sam, you also said that you had an observation about the Edge that you want to share. Yes. Yes. We should say you guys that both Sam and Cassie watched this with us and Ainsley and Ainsley. Yes. Okay, Sam,
what was your observation? Yes. The first half of this movie before they reached the bear is Lord of the Rings. Is Lord of the Rings just like three people walking through a forest, like laying down wisdom? Honestly, most of it, yes. Wow. Well, I'm intrigued. Instead of bears, there's orcs. Yes, exactly.
Yes. But they still want to kill you. Yeah. Maybe I'll watch it. I doubt it. I mean, that would be epic. Why don't we take a break, and then we'll finish breaking down the edge. Angela, you are still tracking the wind,
and I've got two more pieces of Charles wisdom for you. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, you often hear about the red flags to look for in a relationship. But what if? What if we changed that focus and started making a list of the green flags that we were looking for in friends and partners?
You know, like more like instead of framing it, here's what I'm avoiding, be like, here's what I wanna run toward. Okay. Well, if you're not sure what your list of green flags is, therapy can help you identify them. And your list of green flags is, therapy can help you identify them. And you know BetterHelp is fully online, making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. You can access
a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. You can also switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Discover your relationship green flags with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's Better Help. H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments? Sounds like you're at the top office ladies. and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. All right, we are back. Now, quick summary. Here is what has happened so far in the movie that we broke down last week. Three men, Bob, Charles, and Stephen have been stranded in the wilderness after a small plane they were traveling in was hit by a flock of geese.
While trying to survive in the wilderness, this group is also being stalked by a bear. And then Stephen cut his leg trying to make a spear and Bob hung the bloody rag on a tree instead of burying it like he was told. He was specifically told to bury the bloody rag. And he didn't. The blood attracted the bear who charged their campsite. Stephen is dead. He was killed by the bear. Bob and Charles are alive and it's snowing. Yeah it's the next morning. Bob and Charles have made it through the night. Now they're huddled together and it is really coming down with some snow. And you know, they haven't eaten.
They need food. So Charles makes a little wooden trap and they're gonna try to trap a squirrel and they do it. It's so great because the shot is just their two faces peering over a log with such anticipation of eating the squirrel. But then in the distance they hear a helicopter. Yeah. But they are really far from a clearing and they run and they run and they run and the helicopter doesn't see them. And this is when Bob
this is his moment that he becomes absolutely despondent. Yeah, and Charles, I don't know if it's because, well, honestly, I wrote this, Charles, read the room. He starts telling Bob, who's very distraught, he starts saying this, do you know that you can make fire from ice? You can make fire from ice. Bob isn't listening.
Charles goes, hello, I'm talking to you! Do you know how that could be done, Bob? And Bob is just so pissed off. And I just want to say, Charles, no one wants to hear trivia right now. Your friend just got eaten by a bear. You're starving. You just missed the opportunity to get rescued. No one wants a little piece of trivia right now. Yeah. Also, Bob is very winded, but Charles is not. Bob ran faster. Okay.
He did. Okay. But now they're realizing that's it. That's the only time that helicopter is gonna search that area. Their only option is truly to walk out of this situation. They are going to have to save themselves. Being rescued is no longer an option. No. Bob did have a whole spiral, you know. He goes off on
Charles, says like, you know, you make me sick, and you know, then again he's crying. And Charles is just like, we've got to get to the river, we've got to walk alongside the river to get out of here. And the two men start to walk through this valley and lady, one hour, six seconds, you can hear the wind. The wind. Woo. It really makes you feel so alone and isolated.
It's like they're never going to see another person ever again. Here's what I wrote about this scene where Bob is losing it and Charles is trying to like, you know, carry on carrying on. I wrote during my cancer journey, which was my wilderness, I would go back and forth between being Bob and Charles. And that's why I love this movie, because I feel like these two points of view are in all of us, right? Like, in a moment of crisis, who's going to win? Bob or Charles? But we need both. We need to have the release. We need to have the tears. We need to have the doubt.
We aren't robots. But eventually we need Charles to get us, be like, okay, did you get it out? Are you good? And now let's move forward. That's why I love the movie. I feel like we all have both of us in them. Although- Bob and Charles.
Bob and Charles. And then, you know, then sometimes we're Steven. Sometimes the situation is just gonna get us. It just is. There's nothing you can do. You can't win them all. I know. Who would you be in the wilderness?
Like if you were in this movie, if you were having this literal thing happen to you, not metaphorical, are you Bob, Charles or Stephen? Who are you? Oh God, I don't wanna be any of them. I don't wanna be out there. I don't wanna go 80 miles and further into the wilderness, especially after a guy just told me
that birds can take down this plane. I'm not going. You're not there. I'm Mickey. You're back in the lodge. Yeah. Sam, Cassie, who are you? I think I'm Bob. I'm Bob too, Sam.
Okay. It's okay, it's okay. Cassie? I do think I'm Charles unless I get hurt, then I'm definitely Steven. Oh no. Yeah. Yeah, I don't know.
I don't wanna go. All right, let's see, Where are we? Oh, they are gonna walk along the river and Charles is gonna go fishing because they really need to eat. They're not gonna get out of here if they don't get some food. I don't know what happened to their squirrel. They heard the helicopter. They ran away. The squirrel is still in the cage on the log. I know. They couldn't have gone back for it. It was a whole squirrel. I don't know Bob was very upset. Well Charles was talking trivia. I would have gone to get it. That was another error they made. Yeah well now they're trying to fish using
parts of Charles's watch. He has to keep dismantling this gift from his wife to survive. He uses almost all of it. He does, but guess what happens while he's fishing? The bear comes back y'all. Mm-hmm. He comes back. Charles gets back to the campfire and they they make like a circle of fire around their fire and they're standing in the circle of fire. And this is when Charles realizes that this bear is tracking them. Yeah. And they only have one option. Charles says they're going to have to kill them. They're going to have to kill the bear.
Charles says, I'm not going to die here. No siree. I'm going to kill the bear. This is wisdom moment number three. The most famous. This is after Bob says, how? How are we going to kill the bear? And Charles says, we're going to use the same principle as the deadfall.
We're going to use the bear's own weight and we're going to get it to impale itself onto a spear that we've whittled when it's attacking us. And Bob's like, well, how are we going to get the bear to come out? And he's like, we're going to have to lure him. We're going to lure the bear to us. Except Charles says lure. Lure. And then in this moment we have Bob snark. In this crazy life-threatening moment Bob goes I'm sorry how do we lure and he mocks Charles. You have to hear it. What are we going to use to bait him, Charles? We lure him. What? We lure him.
You know, Maasai boys in Africa, 11 years old, they kill lions with spears. How do we lure him? Seriously, Bob, we don't need your snark right now. No, we do not. But lady, Charles doesn't care about need your snark right now. No, we do not. But lady, Charles doesn't care about Bob's snarky attitude. And what comes next is my next piece of Charles wisdom, and it is maybe my favorite Charles speech in the whole movie.
I have a clip. Here it is. I have to distract him and trap him, but it can be done. Do you believe it, Bob? Do you believe it? is. He's ahead of us all the time. It's like he's reading our minds. He's stalking us for God's sake see You want to die out here, huh? Well then die I tell you what I'm not gonna die. I'm sorry. I'm not gonna die I'm gonna kill the bear.
Sid, I'm gonna kill the bear. Sid, I'm gonna kill the bear. Sid! Sid, I'm gonna kill the bear! Sid! I'm gonna kill the bear. Sid again! I'm gonna kill the bear. And again!
I'm gonna kill the bear! Good! What one man can do, another can do. What one man can do, another can do. Say it again! What one man can do, another can do. Say it again! What one man can do, another can do! Yeah!
Today, I'm gonna kill the motherf*****. That's right, folks. That's right. Wisdom moment number three. what one man can do, another can do. We got a letter from Alexis B. in Winnipeg who said, Hi, office ladies. The reason I wrote today is that I want to send a special thank you to you, Jenna. I have never seen The Edge, and I'm so sorry. I likely never will. It sounds too scary.
But Jenna's quoting of the film has been playing in my head this last while, helping me to get through some more challenging times. Reminding myself that what one man can do, another can do, has brought light at the end of the tunnel, even if I don't know what the whole story is with the bear. As always, thank you both very much for your vulnerability, motivation, laughter, and your
beautiful friendship. Looking forward to all your future episodes and the ones I will undoubtedly re-listen to along the way. Well, Alexis, I played this audio clip just for you so that you could hear it. You don't have to watch the whole movie, Alexis. Or you can listen to the podcast and then you don't have to be super scared. That's right. We were breaking it down for you, but what one man can do another can do. Sam, you said you woke up this morning quoting it. Yes, I was walking around making eggs in my apartment alone going, but one man can do
another man can do. Just hyping myself up for the day. Yeah, it's a really good hype line. It is. It really is. I love it lady. I love it. Well you guys, I have to, sorry, this is not as powerful as that, but I have to share at one hour 15 minutes and 40 seconds, the wind is back. The wind is so haunting to me in this movie. Guess what? It is blowing
the blood-stained cloth that they have tied at the tip of the spear. They are going to try to lure this bear with the smell of blood. There is no dialogue for over two minutes as they wait for the bear. It's just wind and waiting and it is so creepy and I think you have to hear it. This is two minutes of wind? Yes. Okay. It's worth it lady. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Oh, the bear's there. Did you hear it? Did you hear how much wind and waiting?
That is some serious suspense. Very suspenseful. That is a lot of wind, lady. And I also thought that was a really nice example of the score, remember? Roger Ebert pointed out the amazing musical score by Jerry Goldsmith. Yeah, it's good. It's good. Combo wind and music. But look how long you're waiting and you're just listening to the wind and waiting for this bear. Well, the bear comes. Oh, yeah.
Comes right at them. And they try to lure the bear to this like X that they've marked on the ground with some twigs because they've made somehow, how do they make all this stuff? A big like something with like these wooden spears coming out of it. They made like an old school medieval sort of like pendulum swing, a giant ball with a bunch of pointy spears that they're gonna like cut the rope and it's gonna swing and it's gonna hit the bear. They've also spent a ton of time whittling. Oh. And they have one knife, if I'm correct here. Yeah, they had to take turns. They had to whittle their
hearts out. They spent all night whittling. They didn't sleep, they whittled all night. They certainly did and unfortunately when they let the big medieval thingy, spiky thing down, it hits a tree first, which sort of breaks the momentum and then it hits the bear and it's like oh my gosh it's like nothing to the bear. The bear's like, it's like the bear got slapped and he's like hey what the hell. Then the bear's mad. Then the bear's really mad and I kind of feel like we can't do a breakdown of this movie and not hear the bear. Oh let's hear him. Rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr rrr. Yes. He's terrifying. Growling in their faces and all they have are like these self-whittled wooden branches
with a little pointy thing on the end. They end up running away. They, again, this is another like long pursuit, like through woods, down an embankment, into some water. But lady, in their night of whittling they planned this because they're gonna dive off the embankment, you're gonna roll down it as fast they can to give them a little bit of time to go to their second staging area. Yes, with many spears. A lot more spears. You guys they had to do
this in the dark. They had to whittle, whittle, whittle, whittle, whittle all night, then they had to go down an embankment in the dark. They had to cross a river in the dark. Then they had to place their other spears. You kind of just have to go with it because that's a little, you could call bullsh-t on how much they had to do in a night,
but you gotta let it go. You gotta let it go, you do. They get down to their little waterfront fortress thing. Spear area. And to his credit, when Charles is in peril with the bear, Bob does step up and antagonize the bear, and then the bear turns on Bob and swipes him and gets him. Sends him flying, I mean the bear knocked them both,
like pew pew. Yeah, but Charles runs and gets a spear,ends them flying. I mean the bear knocked them both like yeah pew pew. Yeah but Charles runs and gets a spear and he does this amazing moment where he sort of braces the back of the spear into some rocks. To really anchor it. Yes and then his option is he has to let the bear charge him and like fall on him. Impale himself. And he does. The bear impales himself and then collapses dead on top of Charles. 1700 pounds collapsing on Charles. Yeah.
I kind of thought he was a goner. Well, he's not. They did it. They killed this bear and we're gonna cut to them cooking the bear meat over a fire. Yes and according to James's review I know you're not a fan of him here is his best anti-lawyer joke in a movie in 1997. I'm sorry again his negative review is another positive review. Okay fine but two stars whatever again what does it
take James what does it take? There are a lot of movies released in 1997, you guys. This is high praise for the best anti-lawyer joke. Bob is going to say to Charles, a month ago, old Smokey here would have reared up and you probably would have called your lawyer. And Charles says, nah, I wouldn't do that to an animal. I wouldn't do that to an animal. Baboom, choo! Yeah. Yep. On this night, they don't whittle anything, but they do cook the bear, eat the bear,
skin the bear, make clothing out of the bear, make a backpack out of the bear. This sent me down the rabbit hole of how long does it take to skin a bear and all the things. It takes a really long time especially with a knife that size. I feel like I know too much now about how to even skin a bear like I know you started the anus. What?, you do. Why? Don't tell me. Anyway, you leave the paws and the head on. It's a whole thing. This would have taken so much time.
Listen, it's possible that they did camp here for a period of time. It's not clear. It's not clear. It is a time cut. Yes, there could have been a passage of time because the next big scene is them on a mountaintop, they turn around and they are in full bearskin outfits. I said this is the one shot I'm calling this **** on. It looks crazy. Yeah, they are, they have a sort of renewed confidence. They have eaten. This thing is not stalking them anymore. And now they've made a compass
out of Charles's pocket watch. And this is when Charles says, you know what, when this is over, when we get home, I'm gonna start my life over again. Yeah, he wants a do-over. He does. Wanna point out at one hour and 25 minutes, wind is whistling through the mountains
as they start their walk. You just feel the vastness. There's a wind placement. If I could go to the sound editor and give them a high five for really good wind placement, I would. Well, I don't disagree. And on that note, let's take a break. And when we come back, we will get to the final act of the movie.
MUSIC All right, we are back and after a very long time of walking in their bare skin outfits, Bob and Charles come across a shack. A shack with a canoe. And lady, I needed a bigger reaction at seeing this shack. I hear you because how f***ing excited are you to see this shack? I'm so excited. Are you to see this shack? I'm so excited. Are you kidding me? And by the way, it is, this shack looks like it has been abandoned forever
and is falling apart and is in no way any kind of real shelter, except when you have been living out in the wilderness for however long they've been gone. Yeah. This looks like a mansion. Yeah. I needed them to be like, oh my god, or something.
Yeah, they just sort of just walk in and get down to the business of looking through all the contents of the shelter. This is my favorite part of survival films, by the way, is when the people find something like this, where they get to root for all their new supplies. It's the part of zombie movies that I like, like in Dawn of the Dead, when they go through the mall
and they get all the things they wanna gather for their survival. I don't watch zombie movies. I'm not gonna, yeah. But I know the moment you're talking about. I just hate zombies. Here's the thing, as they're walking up to this kind of abandoned cabin,
Charles sees one of those bear traps in the ground. Yeah, one of the ones that it's like covered up with earth, but it goes down a hole. And there's spiky things sticking out like they've... Self-whittled. Self-whittled, spiky things. And he just kind of clocks it and walks around it. But that's going to be important later. I it and walks around it. But that's gonna be important later.
I'm glad you mentioned it. So they get inside and here's what they found. They found a teapot. Some whiskey. A rifle with bullets. An old map. A map. Yeah.
And a canoe that floats. That floats. Oh, they're so excited. They're gonna like kind of gather themselves. Mm-hmm. Bob is hitting the whiskey pretty hard. Charles is like, I'm gonna make tea. Oh, was that your favorite part of the movie? Was this like how I loved the John Wick coffee maker moment? Was this that for you? Where he's gonna, he's in the wilderness, he's gonna make himself some tea real quick. I was so excited for him to have a hot cup of tea. Yeah. But Charles gets distracted.
Well, yes, because now is going to begin the final chapter of this movie. Chapter one, we had man against the wilderness. Chapter two, man against bear. And now the final chapter is man against man. Because as Charles is starting the fire for his teapot, guess what he finds? He finds the receipt for both watches and the knife. So he knows now that his wife bought all three including Bob's watch that was engraved thanking Bob for quote, all the nights.
Yeah, love Mickey. So Charles is looking at this receipt. He's adding it all up in his brain. He knows what happened. Meanwhile, Bob is just swinging whiskey and loading the rifle with bullets. Yeah. Charles looks at him and says, can't do it sober, huh?
And he says, yeah, I guess you can kill me now that you don't need me anymore. Now that you know you can just ride this canoe down the river. You don't really need me. And Bob is like, you had no business being with that broad. Everybody knows it. She was just with you for the money. Yeah. He says, Let's go marches him outside. Wants him to turn around. He's going to shoot him in the back. Yeah. Charles won't turn around. Lady. I have a question. What is it? Was Bob always going to kill Charles? This is where it is confusing. It is confusing. Yeah at first, I just think that he was kind of happy to have an affair with his wife
and didn't like Charles, but was just going to do this photo shoot. He's a douchebag, but he isn't going to kill him. Right. When did he decide to kill him? I think that what Charles was picking up on at the beginning of the movie when he says, how are you gonna kill me, Bob?
He's picking up on the idea that he knows that Bob has it in him, that he's the kind of man who has thought, wouldn't it be great if Charles died and then we got all the money? I don't think he thinks, oh, this man will actually murder me, but he knows he's had the thought. That's what I think the scab he's picking at when he says that, that he says,
I know the character of you. You're a man of poor character, because you would wish me dead so you can have my wife and my money. OK. And then that's what I imagine. I don't think, think obviously Bob didn't make a flock of geese fly into this plane and make them stranded. But it would explain why he didn't stick around after the plane crash or took off running when
bears attacking Stephen. Yeah. But now he sees his opportunity. Yeah, at this point, Charles could just, quote, not survive this. And he can go back and have the wife and all the money. So yeah, but I don't think he was always going to kill Charles. It wasn't. This is a man of opportunity. That's the character that he is, right?
Yeah. He takes advantage of opportunity. That's the character that he is, right? Yeah. He takes advantage of opportunities. This is probably an unpopular opinion, but I wrote, I didn't need this part. What part? Man against man. Oh, I love man against man. I liked the survival.
I like the outwitting. This is the outwitting. This is the part of Survivor where you have to outwit. Yeah. Yeah. Well, Bob has him outside now. Yeah. He has him at gunpoint.
And Charles will not turn around. He doesn't think Bob's ultimately gonna do it. And Bob kind of takes a step back right into the bear pit, full of spiky things. Yes, and his leg gets impaled. Like he has clearly, the way it's twisted, it's clearly broken during the fall and it has a giant spike through it now, a wooden spike.
It's totally mangled. Here's my question, did Charles intend to push him back into that bear pit? Yes. Yes. This is where he's the rabbit with the pipe. Correct. Yeah, he knew it. Well now Charles jumps into the pit to help him.
I mean, carefully, he doesn't jump into it, but he gets down in there. Yep, he takes all the bullets out of the gun. He tourniquets his leg, and then we've got a cut. We never see him do it, but somehow he gets him out of the pit and puts him on the table up in the cabin. It's fine, jump cut, it's fine. It's fine.
Bob is in a ton of pain. He passes out from the pain. Yeah. And Charles is now going to sit and weirdly read the first aid brochure as if there's anything in there. There's a first aid kit in the wall of this cabin and he's reading this brochure
as if he's gonna find any information on how to help this leg. Like every time I see this part of the movie, I'm like, what does he think he's finding in this booklet? While he's sitting there, lady, I want you to know all you can hear. Oh, boy. Is it wind, lady? It is wind.
More wind. One hour, 40 minutes. Bob finally comes to, and Charles tells him, you know what, we're going to get out of here. I want to point out, as they board the canoe, neither of them have their fancy bearskin outfits anymore. No. They've ditch their fancy bearskin outfits anymore. No. They've ditched the bearskin look. Well Charles is still wearing his bear tooth around his neck. Yes but he does still have his necklace. Not the poncho he spent so many
hours making. Right. Yeah. Or the bearskin jacket that Bob had on. Yes. Again we don't ever see how Charles got Bob in the canoe, but they're now sailing down the river. And they're going to have a conversation. Bob is going to ask Charles, why did you save me after everything that's happened? And Charles says, it's a challenge. And Bob says, I think it's because you've never
had a friend. Yeah. They have found this little island in the middle of the river and they have made a fire. To kind of warm up Bob who's not looking great. Not looking great. I know I should not have found this humorous, but Bob repeatedly says, I'm not feeling 100%. Well, it doesn't look good. You think?
Yeah, he doesn't look good. And that's when Bob is going to, he's gonna start crying. And he kind of knows he's dying. And he says, I've done nothing with my life and I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry, I want you to know something. Mickey was never part of the plan to kill you. No.
Well, I guess now it seems like there was a plan to kill him. He just says she was never in on it. Any of this business out here, she wasn't in on it. Yeah. I, what? Well, we don't know. And Charles is like, Bob, come on, it's fine. Bob, don't die on me.
Don't die on me, Bob. And then what do we hear in the distance? What do we hear? Helicopter. A helicopter. Charles is so excited. He starts waving his coat in the air and you kind of think the helicopter is not gonna see him.
And then at the last minute, it turns towards them. And you know they're saved. Yes. And he runs back to Bob. And he's like, they're coming. We are saved. Bob's dead. Bob's dead.
And remember what Charles said, most men die of in the wilderness. He died of shame because he couldn't go back. He couldn't face himself. And I don't think it's the wilderness. He died of shame because he couldn't go back. He couldn't face himself. And I don't think it's the affair. What he couldn't face was that he was willing to kill Charles. He couldn't live with himself. And Charles saved him even after that. So he died of shame. Well now the helicopter is arriving back at the lodge. Yeah there's's all these reporters. Yeah, they're kind of
being held back by like, yeah, police and Charles gets off the plane. He starts walking up to the lodge. I mean, and he looks like he's been through it. Well, he has he has been through it. Yeah. And Charles as he walks past Krusty Stiles says to Stiles, why is the rabbit unafraid to which styles replies because he's smarter than the panther and they share a knowing smile that's pretty dark lady yeah we're also now gonna see Bob's body is being unloaded from the plane you know he's all covered up and Mickey you see Mickey standing there stoically waiting for her husband, but then also kind of, she's tearing up. She's looking at, she sees Bob down, make it.
There's all these reporters have gathered and Charles goes up and looks at Mickey for a long time, gives her a hug and then puts Bob's watch in her hand. And then puts Bob's watch in her hand. Yep. For all the nights. Mm-hmm. And then the reporters are clamoring for a statement, and Charles is going to give us the final wisdom from the movie. Here it is. Ah, we're all put to the test, but it never comes in the form or at the point we would prefer,
does it? That's right. In our lifetimes, every single one of us is put to the test. It's not going to come in the form or at the time you would prefer. But we'll all be put to the test somehow, some way. And so, are you gonna walk out of it? Are ya? Are you gonna die of shame? Which to me is just another way of saying are you gonna give up? Are you gonna give up and give in?
Are you gonna walk out of it? Because what one man can do another can do. That's right. Your test is no different than someone else's test. It might be a different form. It might be a different time. But we will all have a test. Can you rise to the occasion?
That's what this movie is asking. And that is why I love this movie. Yeah. As you were saying that, I thought about, it's a verse. I'm going to paraphrase it. God is no respecter of persons, meaning God does not show favoritism or partiality towards any individual. Like you get what you get. And that's what I was thinking. And what do you do with it? What do you do with it? Yeah.
Yeah. Well, at the end, a reporter asked Charles, how did his friends die? And he really tears up. It's very emotional. And he says, they died saving my life. And it's making me tear up because of the other part of this movie which is that you do not
do it alone. You don't do any of it alone. I did not do my cancer journey alone. Angela you were there every step of the way and so was my husband and so were all the nurses and the doctors and so were all the parents of my children's friends and there is a community for all of us when we are put to the test. There is. You have to find it. You have to let it in. Mm-hmm.
You know? People will give themselves to you in so many ways to help you. They will. Yeah. I thought a lot about that last line of the movie. I'm always curious about first lines of movies and last lines. You know, what are the bookends? Yeah. What was the first line of this movie? The first line of this movie is actually by the character Mickey, and she turns to her husband, Charles, as she takes in the vast wilderness and she says, Charles, isn't this great?
Wow. Yeah. And what I think Charles is talking about when he says they died saving my life, because Stephen didn't save his life. Bob didn't really either. But in a way way all of it made him realize that he wants a do-over.
Yeah, I also think that in a way just their being there did save his life because it gave Charles purpose. To get out. He wasn't ever alone. Right. Being alone in the wilderness is a lot harder than being with two other people in the wilderness yeah whatever your wilderness is right you know and so just their presence kept him going yeah yeah I think that's true you You know? Well, that was the edge, you guys.
And Lady, I know I watched this as a Galentine's gift to you, but maybe it was a gift to myself. Well, I hope it was. I hope it was the greatest gift ever. I mean, it was a good gift. It was a good gift. I don't know if it's the greatest gift ever, but I really did enjoy it.
Well, thank you, Lady. Thank you to everyone for writing in and for watching this along with us. I really mean it. I appreciate you sharing this movie that I love so much. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey.
Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.